announcing the united states is
targeting the main artery of russia's
economy
we're banning all of russian oil and gas
and energy
that means russian oil will no longer be
acceptable at u.s ports and the american
people will
deal another powerful blow to putin's
war machine
this is a move that has strong
bipartisan support for congress and i
believe in the country
americans of rallied support have
rallied to support their ukrainian
people and made it clear we will not be
part of subsidizing putin's war
this made we made this decision in close
consultation with our allies and our
partners around the world particularly
in europe
because a united response to putin's
aggression has been my overriding focus
to keep
all
nato and all of eu and our allies
totally united
we're moving forward this ban
understanding that many of our european
allies and partners may not be in a
position to join us
the united states produces far more oil
domestically than all of europe all the
european countries combined
in fact we're a net exporter of energy
so we can take this step when others
cannot
but we're working closely with europe
and our partners to develop a long-term
strategy to reduce their dependence on
russian energy as well
our teams are actively discussing how to
make this happen and today
we remain united we reign united in our
purpose to keep pressure mounting on
putin and his war machine
this is a step that we're taking to
inflict further pain on putin
but there will be cost as well here in
the united states i said i would level
with the american people from the
beginning
and when i first spoke to this i said
defending freedom is going to cost it's
going to cost us as well in the united
states
republicans and democrats understand
alike understand that republicans and
democrats alike have been clear that we
must do this
over the last week i've spoken with
president stalinski several times to
hear from him about the situation on the
ground and to consult
and continue to consult with
our european allies and about u.s
support for ukraine and ukrainian people
thus far we've provided more than one
billion dollars in security assistance
to ukraine
shipments of defensive weapons are
arriving ukraine every day from the
united states
and we the united states are the ones
coordinating the delivery of our allies
and partners of similar uh weapons from
germany to finland to the netherlands
we're a com we're we're
working that out
we're also providing humanitarian
support for the ukrainian people
both those still in ukraine and those
who have fled safely to a neighboring
country
we're working with humanitarian
organizations to surge tens of thousands
of tons of food water and medical
supplies into ukraine and with more on
the way
over the weekend i sent secretary
blinken to visit
our border between the border between
poland and ukraine and to moldova
to see what the situation was firsthand
and report back
general milley chairman of the joint
chiefs of staff of our defense
department is also what was also in
europe meeting with his counterparts and
allies on nato's eastern flank to
reassure them those countries bordering
russia nato countries that we will keep
our nato commitment a sacred commitment
article of article 5.
the vice president harris is going to be
traveling to meet with our allies in
poland and romania later this week as
well
i've made it clear the united states
will share in the responsibility of
caring for the refugees so the costs do
not fall entirely on the european
country's border in ukraine
and yesterday i spoke with my
counterparts in france germany and the
united kingdom while russia is
escalating violence against ukraine and
the steps that we're going to take
together with our allies and partners
around the world to respond to this
aggression
we are enforcing the most significant
package of economic sanctions in history
and is causing significant damage to
russia's economy
it has caused russian economy to fight
frank crankly crater
the russian ruble is now down to 50
by 50 since putin's announced his war
one ruble
is now worth less than one american
penny
one ruble less than one american penny
and preventing russia's central bank
from propping up the ruble and to keep
its value up they're not going to be
able to do that now
we cut russia's largest banks from the
international financial system and has
crippled their ability to do business
with the rest of the world
in addition
we're choking off russia's access to
technology like semiconductors that are
and uh and sap it's uh its economic
strength and weakened its military for
years to come
major companies are pulling out of
russia entirely without even being asked
not by us over the weekend visa
mastercard american express they all
suspended their services in russia all
of them
joining a growing list of american and
global companies from ford to nike to
apple they've suspended their operations
in russia
the u.s stock exchange has hauled a
trading of many russian securities
the private sector is united against
russia's vicious war of choice
the u.s department of justice has
assembled a dedicated task force to go
after
russian for the crimes of russian
oligarchs and we're joining with our
european allies to find and seize their
yachts their luxury apartments their
private jets and all their ill-begotten
gains to make sure that they share in
the pain of putin's war
these by the way are giant yachts you
put some of them in your press i mean
some of them are i think i've read one
was over 400 feet long i mean it's uh
this is worth hundreds of millions of
dollars
the decision today is not without cost
here at home
putin's war is already hurting american
families at the gas pump
since putin began his military buildup
on ukrainian borders just since then
the price of the gas at the pump in
america went up 75 cents
and with this action it's going to go up
further
i'm going to do everything i can to
minimize putin's price hike here at home
in coordination with our partners we've
already announced that we're releasing
60 million barrels of oil from our joint
oil reserves half of that 30 billion
million excuse me is coming from the
united states
and we're taking steps to ensure the
reliable supply of global energy
are also going to keep working
with every tool at our disposal protect
american families and businesses
now
let me let me say this
to the oil and gas companies and to the
finance firms that pack them
we understand putin's war against the
people of ukraine is causing prices to
rise we get that that's self-evident but
but but but
it's no excuse to exercise excessive
price increases or padding profits or
any kind of effort to exploit this
situation
or amer or american consumers exploit
them
russia's aggression is costing us all
and it's no time for profiteering or
price gouging i want to be clear about
what we'll not tolerate
but i also want to acknowledge those
firms and oil and gas industries that
are pulling out of russia and joining
other businesses that are leading by
example
this is a time when we have to do our
part and make sure we're not taking
we're not taking advantage look let me
be clear
about two other points first
it's simply not true that my
administration or policies are holding
back domestic energy production
that's simply not true
even amid the pandemic companies in the
united states pump more oil during my
first year in office than they did
during my predecessor first year
we're approaching a record levels of oil
and gas production in the united states
and we're on track to set a record of
oil production next year
in the united states
90
of onshore oil production takes place on
land that isn't owned by the federal
government
and of the remaining 10 percent that
occurs on federal land the oil and gas
industry has millions of acres leased
they have 9 000 permits to drill now
they could be drilling right now
yesterday last week last year
they have 9 000
to drill onshore that are already
approved
so let me be clear
let me be clear they are not using them
for production now that's their decision
these are the facts
we should be honest about the facts
second this crisis is a stark reminder
to protect our economy over the long
term we need to become energy
independent i've had numerous
conversations over the last three months
with our european friends of how they
have to wean themselves off of us
russian oil it's just not it's not
tenable
it should motivate us to accelerate the
transition of clean energy this is a
perspective extended our european allies
share
and the future where together we can
achieve greater independence
loosening environmental regulations and
pulling back clean energy investment
won't let me explain won't will not
lower energy prices for families
but transforming our economy to run on
electric vehicles powered by clean
energy with tax credits to help american
families winterize their homes and use
less energy that will that will help
and if we can if we do we can
it will mean that no one has to worry
about price of gas pump in the future
that'll mean tyrants like putin won't be
able to use fossil fuels as weapons
against other nations
and it will make america a world leader
manufacturing and exporting clean energy
technologies of the future to countries
all around the world
this is the goal we should be racing
toward
over the last two weeks the ukrainian
people have inspired the world and i
mean that in a literal sense they've
inspired the world with their bravery
their patriotism their defiant
determination to live free
putin's war putin's war has caused
enormous suffering and needless loss of
life
on women children everyone in ukraine
both ukraine and i might add russians
ukrainian leaders as well as leaders
around the world have repeatedly called
for a ceasefire for humanitarian relief
for real diplomacy
but putin seems determined to continue
on his murderous path no matter the cost
putin's now targeting cities and has
been targeting cities and civilian
schools hospitals apartment buildings
last week he attacked the largest
nuclear power plant in europe with an
apparent disregard for the potential of
triggering a nuclear meltdown
he has already turned 2 million
ukrainians into refugees
russia may continue to grind out its
advance at a horrible price
but this much is already clear
ukraine will never be a victory for
putin
putin may be able to take a city
but he'll never be able to hold the
country
and if we do not respond to putin's
assault on global
peace and stability today the cost of
freedom and to the american people will
be even greater tomorrow
so we're going to continue to support
the brave ukrainian people as they fight
for their country and i call on congress
to pass the 12 billion ukraine
assistance package that i have asked
them for
of late
ukrainian people are demonstrating by
their physical courage that they are not
about to just let putin take what he
wants
that's clear
they'll defend their freedom
their democracy their lives
and we're going to keep providing
security assistance economic assistance
and humanitarian assistance we're going
to support them against tyranny
oppression violent acts of subjugation
people everywhere and i i think it's
maybe even surprised some of you all
people everywhere are speaking up for
freedom
when the history of this war is written
putin's war on ukraine will have left
russia weaker
and the rest of the world's stronger
and god bless all those heroes in
ukraine and now i'm off to texas thank
you very very much i know there's a lot
of people
i know
i know there's a lot of
questions but there's a lot more that
has to be made clear and i'm gonna hold
on that until we get more information
thank you appreciate it